stephen king's bugs have been adapted to
film or television over a hundred times
making him the all-time king of
adaptations from a living authors work
but whilst some adaptations of his works
ranked among the most beloved films of
all time
others are hardly worth remembering at
all to help you pass out the good from
the bad he is a list of the 10 worst and
10 best Stephen King adaptational in any
particular order but starting of the
ones that probably don't deserve your
time Sall nine years after appearing
together in 1408 which we'll be talking
about much later John Cusack and samuel
l.jackson reunited for sell
unfortunately it wasn't a reunion really
worth having the plot centers on Clara
dal a man who's determined to reunite
with his son after a malevolent
electronic signal turned cellphone users
into mindless killers along the way he
teams up with train driver Tom McCourt
in order to better their chances of
survival while the novel was generally
well received for its technophobic take
on the zombie trope the movie suffered a
far less positive fate it's stunk
graveyard shift
1990s graveyard shift still stands as
one of the worst King adaptations in a
main textile mill where a drifter has
taken a job several overnight employees
have died and the egomaniacal Foreman
sends a drifter and others down into the
basement to investigate King's short
story didn't translate well to the
screen the saving grace of the film as a
crazy exterminator played by Brad Dourif
and I'd be the understatement here but
even that's not enough to save this
movie thinner despite having excellent
source material Tom Hollands 1990
adaptation of thinner just couldn't pull
it off when an obese a morally bankrupt
lawyer
Billy Halleck accidentally runs over and
kills a gypsy woman he uses his court
connections to get off the hook the
woman's elderly father takes revenge by
placing a curse upon Halleck one which
soon has him uncontrollably losing
weight to the point of emaciation the
premise is definitely scary but the
effect falls flat on the big screen
especially when we're confronted with
the actor in a terribly fake latex fat
suit that only gets slightly less
hilarious as he sheds two pounds Maximum
Overdrive
stephen king himself step behind the
lens for the 1986 adaptation of his own
Maximum Overdrive it was my first
pictures director I sort of enjoyed it
others however did not this movie puts
earth in the tail of a comet after which
once the dirt machines are suddenly come
to life and go on a murderous rampage
against humans
[Music]
that's a truckstop a bland protagonist
played by Emilio Estevez and an odd
assortment of other unremarkable
characters settle in to wait out the
living trucks to have them pinned down
inside while Maximum Overdrive does have
a killer soundtrack from ac/dc and a few
neat shots peppered throughout the movie
is still a maximum dud needful things
although the novel needful things as a
favorite among King fans the 1993 film
adaptation of the story might leave
audiences ready to sell their own souls
to the devil just to get it over with
set in Castle Rock main needful things
follows a character named Leland gaunt
opening an antique store called you
guessed it needful things many of the
town's residents soon find their heart's
desires fulfilled by the stores items
some of which have a distinctly
supernatural bent but gaunt prices are
nearly too good to be true
rather than heaps of cash gone just
wants to town people to play pranks on
each other but those small misdeeds end
up igniting some intense rivalries and
things turned violent very quickly if
that sounds like an intriguing story
that's because it is Kings written
version of needful things are certainly
worthy of your time but the movies
failure to translate the character
development of many players involved
renders this movie a total wash at least
we got a pretty great Rick and Morty
episode out of it a typewriter that
generates best-selling murder mysteries
and then makes the murders happen in
real life the Mangler tobe Hooper's 1994
adaptation of Kings short story the
Mangler somehow spanned the two sequels
but the original is not actually very
good the movie stars Freddy Krueger
actor Robert Englund as a sinister
laundry service owner whose machine has
been possessed by a demon that's been
activated by the presence of blood and
over the counter and assets yes really
the original short story was pretty
threadbare to begin with but the movie
completely ignored the opportunity to
make a campy picked up pokes fun itself
instead we're left with the ridiculous
and gory flick that goes on way too long
and takes itself much too seriously
riding the bullet when King published
his 2000 develop riding the bullet it
was generally well received by critics
and made history as the first mass
distributed
but the story follows Alan Parker an
erotic and depressed college student
whose obsession with worst-case
scenarios nearly drives him to suicide
after receiving news that his mother has
had a stroke Parker decides to hitchhike
so he can reach her before she passes
but instead of culminating in an
exciting thrill ride the movie renders
the journey completely boring add this
to your skip list dream catcher even
Stephen King that didn't completely love
his 2001 novel dream catcher but the
resulting movie was even worse the film
follows four lifelong friends who have
psychic powers of course on a winter
hunting trip to upstate Maine they soon
find themselves caught between invading
aliens and the US military forces trying
to contain them Thomas Jane Damian Lewis
Timothy Olyphant and Jason Lee do find
work as two friends but Morgan Freeman
falls flat as an overzealous commander
with ridiculously distracting eyebrows
what results as an overly long free
associating mess of a movie that could
have been much better if it had just
stuck to one tone the lawnmower man if
you're a fan of this short story from
King's 1978 collection nightshift don't
be fooled by Brad Leonard's 1992 film
that lawnmower man it's an adaptation
and name only other than the title and a
single seen the movie bears little
resemblance to the source material
instead of a nutty little tale about a
lawn mowing service gone horribly wrong
the film steals from the short story
flowers for algernon and Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein for its mish-mashed plot
the movie centers on a doctor who
chooses a mentally impaired greenskeeper
to be the subject of his experiments in
intelligence boosting via virtual
reality and a drug cocktail followed
King's lead on this one and give the
lousy story of the lawnmower man a hard
pass the knight flyer the knight flyer
stays fairly true to King's original
short story but that doesn't mean that
this 1997 adaptation is actually a good
movie miguel ferrer plays tabloid
reporter Richard Dee's who attempts to
hunt down a serial killer who uses a
small aircraft to travel from town to
town leaving a grisly trail of victims
in his wake these soon finds that this
is no ordinary criminal that must also
deal with the competing reporter who's
trying to hardest to steal a scoop while
the short stories version of
was an unlikable cynic who finds his
worldview shaken the movie script and
Ferraz flop performance makes d is a
complete jerk with no redeeming
qualities if you decide to watch the
night flyer you'll probably find
yourself rooting for the bad guy to win
before it's all said and done now that
we've gotten through the shlok here are
the best even king adaptation so far
carry for over 40 years Brian De Palma's
1976 adaptation of Carrie has remained
the classic released just two years
after the book's publication Carrie was
the first adaptation of a Stephen King
work and it's still arguably the best
featuring [ __ ] Spacek in the title role
this supernatural tale sets the hook of
suspense and reels and the viewer
without remorse Spacek as it turns
ethereal and terrifying as Carrie when
to Piper Laurie delivers a commanding
performance as a repressive mother
Margaret even though it's a little dated
today the original vision of Carrie
still holds up as a must watch Stephen
King movie stand by me
unlike many King adaptations stand by me
is more coming-of-age drama than horror
based on Kings a semi-autobiographical
short story the body it follows for
adolescent boys in a small Oregon town
who embark on a journey to find the
corpse of a missing boy thanks to the
off-screen friendship forged by actors
Wil Wheaton River Phoenix Jerry
O'Connell and Corey Feldman the
authenticity of the characters
connection was incredibly real stand by
me remains a classic today and even
those who don't like horror films can
enjoy the Stephen King story the dead
zone David Cronenberg's 1983 adaptation
of Stephen King's the dead zone remains
a more accessible movie than kings more
horrific works the story focuses on
Johnny Smith a man who wakes up from a
coma to discover he has unexplained a
psychic powers and finds himself on a
collision course with destiny during a
pivotal election it's a masterpiece of
thrilling and suspenseful storytelling
that strings viewers alone before the
final climactic scene the Shawshank
Redemption although it registered very
little impact in theaters upon its
release director Frank Darabont's 1994
prison drama the Shawshank Redemption
has gone on to become one of the
best-loved films of the last 30 years
the movie tells the story of two
prisoners serving life sentences
the Shawshank State Penitentiary you
become dear friends despite their
difficult circumstances starring Tim
Robbins and Morgan Freeman in the lead
roles
the Shawshank Redemption is a gritty
tale with a lot of heart and plot points
that transcend the generations The
Shining all work and no play might make
Jack a dull boy
but the shining most certainly isn't
dull Stanley Kubrick's 1980 version of
The Shining still stands as one of the
most beloved King adaptations even if
the author didn't care for himself the
movie follows writer Jack Torrance his
wife Wendy and their young son Danny as
they travel to Colorado to become the
winter caretakers of the opulent and
haunted Overlook Hotel Danny's psychic
abilities allow him to see the
terrifying pasts of the Overlook and his
troubled fathers and the demons are
exploited by the spirit still haunting
the hotel the tale deviates
significantly from the source material
in both characterization and storyline
nevertheless the shrining continues to
be a favorite among horror lovers misery
a psychological thriller directed by Rob
Reiner about fan obsession gone horribly
wrong 1990s misery was a critical and
commercial success that launched Kathy
Bates career and for good reason the
plot follows romance author Paul Sheldon
as he wakes up from a car accident to
find himself in the care of a super fan
named Annie Wilkes you and I were meant
to be together forever
when Wilkes learns that Sheldon has
killed off a favorite character in his
latest novel things start to get grim
and there are some scenes of torment
that won't soon be forgotten or forgiven
by fans of this film The Green Mile
director Frank Darabont returned to the
king library for another prison drama
with 1999's The Green Mile starring Tom
Hanks and Michael Clarke Duncan this
flashback film is told from the
perspective of Paul Edgecombe who
recounts the supernatural events
experienced as a corrections officer
after a very special prisoner arrived on
death row at the cold mountain
penitentiary
it's a soulful and thoughtful movie
which will leave most viewers profoundly
affected after the credits roll Dolores
Claiborne Kathy Bates returned to the
world of Stephen King when she appeared
in the 1995 psychological thriller the
Loras Claybourne based on the novel of
the
same name and directed by Taylor
Hackford the film follows the tale of a
domestic servant who's accused of
murdering her elderly employer
it's a harrowing and suspenseful tale
that will keep audiences guessing until
the end 14:08 in the 2007 psychological
horror film 1408 John Cusack does what
he does best he plays a cynic with love
problems starring as Mike Enslin a
skeptical author who decides to check in
to a notoriously haunted hotel room in
order to investigate it he's joined by
samuel l.jackson as hotel manager Gerald
Olin what follows is a tense and
terrifying descent into Enslin psyche
although it's definitely not on the
level of the shining 14:08 is still a
satisfying and scary haunted hotel
effort that manages to generate genuine
thrills without relying on bucketfuls of
gore it's the feature film debut of it
smashed all sorts of records on its
opening weekend and for good reason it's
a very decent adaptation of one of Kings
most prized books the 1990 TV
mini-series successfully translated the
scares of the novel as well but as
budgeted special effects and bloated
acting moments have kept that version
from aging well in the years since the
new version of it however is much
sharper and more intense and also
presents the hearts and weight of the
novel's characters scary clowns might be
a cultural phenomenon that makes
Pennywise a timely terror but counts on
this one to be more than just a flash in
the pan favorite - thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your loved team
[Music]